vous entrez dans le sanctuaire c'est le
musée Sylvie Vartan dans d'autres termes
c'est la chambre de ma fille
mais enfin alors son père elle le voit
tous les jours
[Musique]
voilà vous habitez à la fantaisie votre
fils
papa c'est candide depuis qu'il est
retraité il a trouvé sa voie c'est le
jardinage alors on va voir toute l'année
on mange des légumes frais
en ce moment
qui aurait pu y avoir c'est le domaine
paternel je sais pas moi je vois que ça
ce sont des fraisiers
c'est un buis bon écoute dans mon
enfance dans les Pyrénées c'est couvert
de de buis alors quand même je les
reconnais il faut pas exagérer ça aussi
début qu'est-ce que c'est ça des
carottes et des carottes
c'est du persil
rectification c'était du persil
voilà alors des poireaux je vois qu'il a
intérêt des points il y a pas grand
chose
et bien ça c'est pas ce sont des
fraisiers ça mon petit ça ce sont des
fraisiers ça c'est un peu plié que la
foudre
voilà alors ça c'est c'est la chèvre que
nous avons appelée très spirituellement
biquette qui nous a été offert par mon
ami Jean Richard voilà tu lui laisses
manger tes salades
oui ça s'appelle le verger d'ailleurs et
quand je suis venu ici quand j'ai acheté
cette maison c'était dans plein automne
et tout ça roulait de fruits il y a
beaucoup de pommes des poires le premier
qui dit des scoubidous je me fâche il y
a des pauvres des poires des des
abricots des pêches des cerises en fait
c'est extraordinaire c'est un régal ici
d'ailleurs
ma fille a même toute une volée de
bambins de gamins plutôt à 13h et cette
c'est rapide gosse ici
la rencontre
voilà alors ici vous allez voir vous
entrez dans le sanctuaire je ne sais pas
si j'ai trop le droit de dévoiler tout
ça c'est pas un secret c'est le musée
c'est le musée Sylvie Vartan dans
d'autres termes c'est la chambre de ma
fille alors voyez il y a combien de
photos je ne sais pas toutes les faux il
y a bien il y a bien quelques exceptions
à la règle Georges Brassens qui vient de
temps en temps ici qui est un ami mais
une photo là là c'est le petit coin
moyen Hervé Vilard Christophe mais alors
là nous avons Sylvie Sylvie en blanc
Sylvie en doré s'il vit avec Brigitte
s'il y avait une montre s'il vit sur la
mer enfin tout ça c'est Sylvie Vartan
Sylvie Sylvie Sylvie un chapeau plein
les collectionne depuis combien de ah je
sais pas elle a une passion pour Sylvie
Vartan
qui traîne mais enfin alors son père
elle le voit tous les jours
[Musique]
c'était un petit bonhomme pas plus haut
que trois pommes les yeux en boule de
gomme mais qui rêvaient de voir
la mer
des silencieux du papier le plus beau
des voiliers il voulait s'embarquer
comme au bon vieux temps
[Musique]
toi qui la connais dis-moi comment
quelle est la mère dit est-ce que c'est
vrai qu'elle peut passer du bleu au vert
réponds-moi
c'est plus grand que ta baignoire que le
bassin du square que les temps au canard
et ça ressemble aussi
la mer
c'est bordé de sable fin de rochers de
pain et puis ça va si loin si loin qu'à
la fin
on l'appelle
elle veut me voir moi oui mais si elle
veut voir la répétition me voir qui
réfléchit mercredi
[Musique]
et alors je vous fais remarquer que j'ai
retourné l'étiquette je sais qu'il faut
pas faire de publicité à la télé
c'est du
bien heureusement que ce n'est pas
l'Olympia tous les jours avant pourquoi
ma petite mère
elle veut pas perdre son fils dans la
fleur de l'âge
depuis 21 ans et oui je suis majeur dans
le métier est-ce que dans le métier il y
a des choses qui vous ont beaucoup
beaucoup marqué en 21 ans
bien sûr
surtout le fait de voir mes aînés je
crois que le premier dans l'ordre
chronologique que j'ai vu c'était Yves
Montand
j'allais encore en classe
et je dois dire que j'en ai pris plein
la poire comme on dit populairement ça
je me suis dit c'est incroyable je
savais pas je ne sortais pas beaucoup
mes parents n'avaient pas la possibilité
ni les moyens de sortir beaucoup je
pensais pas grand-chose on avait la
radio quand même à la maison et je
change j'entendais bien des gens qui
chantaient des trucs amusants moi j'ai
beaucoup traîné chevalier enfin tous les
fantaisistes sur tous les gens qui
chantaient des choses un peu gai
et puis je savais pas du tout qu'on
pouvait faire ça sur scène
qui vous parle je l'ai vu je l'ai vu
danser le Père Noël
et tout ce qui n'y croyaient plus croyez
beurre danser
pour être faim quand ils ont vu dans un
des lieux routiers quand ils ont vu
voltiger le cœur
[Musique]
longtemps sans revenait pompier bonne
année rentrant le rentrer en chantant la
vie commence à 40 ans c'est le match
retour la mimi temps le bleu tranquille
après les ciel d'orage la vie commence à
40 ans
j'ai oublié mes paroles et ça fait rien
cher Agnès de la faille
regardez les tempes grises
la vie commence
à 40 ans la vie commence à 40 ans petit
palais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a quatre ans ça fait 4 ans qu'on
avait pas fait l'Olympia merci
quatre ans
d'abord parce que tous les deux ans
que un artiste qui fait partie des
meubles comme moi ce n'est pas péjoratif
ce que je dis quelqu'un qui qu'on
connaît
se manifeste de temps en temps pour
faire voir c'est un petit peu comme les
collections des couturiers les
collections des couturiers c'est tous
les ans bon ben un artiste quand il
estime non pas qu'il s'est fait à ses
désiré mais quand il estime qu'il faut
que son public
le revoir
et bien quand on est donc un de ces
temps de je vais arriver au bout de ma
phrase donc quand un artiste estime que
son public doit le revoir bien il se
présente moi j'ai pas éprouvé le besoin
de me faire revoir par le public
parisien avant 4 ans parce que parce que
j'avais pas tellement de choses
nouvelles et puis parce que j'ai eu
beaucoup de choses à faire à l'étranger
surtout et ben l'ambiance tu vois c'est
une fête de une fête sud-américaine ça
pourrait être le Pérou la Bolivie
l'équateur on s'en fout hein quelque
chose d'un peu sud-américain les filles
ont des des des des vêtements de ce
style là avec des petits chapeaux ronds
comme ça et puis et le foulard autour du
cou et puis alors elles auraient des
paniers de victuailles des choses un
marché sud-américain mais tu vois pour
touristes alors c'est là que tu mets ce
que tu veux c'est pas mal bonjour madame
Yvonne Mestre mais non tu peux tu peux
venir on est que je vous présente Yvonne
Mestre notre charmante chorégraphe
qu'est-ce que c'est mais non nous avons
la télévision qui est là voilà Yvonne
Mestre bonjour mesdames messieurs
bonjour tout le monde ça va ils vont
justement c'est très bien est en train
de parler avec doudou de de l'histoire
des des pour le marché le marché je lui
ai je lui ai chanté un petit peu la
chanson et puis
ce que tu as demandé me paraîtrait bien
alors d'une part Gilbert vanne et
quelques percussions des machins qu'elle
pourra avoir et alors elles ont des
fruits des des légumes des alcara des
cruches des machins
tu voulais tu veux l'entendre une fois
la couleur gars les gars moi je vous la
fais juste une fois
une dernière fois tu écoutes Yvonne
attention
1 2
c'est bon c'est le bon c'est bon ah
c'est bon mais on s'en fout de ça ah
d'accord deux fois
tout de suite
quand c'est bon quand c'est la fête à
mon village c'est marrant Henri en
chantant danse en bois du vin blanc dans
la rue il y a les étages des marchands
des oignons rosés des erreurs et les
piments
[Musique]
comme tous les ans grand balai de San
Sébastien il y a des hommes et des
hommes venus de loin y en a même mon
Dieu qui partent Marie et pour cette
rencontre de Saint-Sébastien
sur la grande place j'ai acheté des
chaussures de la farine un perroquet une
ceinture et j'ai gagné une tasse de vin
chaud un enfant sans un coup d'un seul
coup de marteau
[Musique]
j'ai mis la farine et la balle de coton
le perroquet lui de là sûrement cheval
je ne suis coiffé j'ai mis mon pantalon
de cuir et mes chaussures à la main
j'attends la main
[Musique]
et les femmes au milieu
pastoriant elles sont jolies dans leur
robe de dentelle elle voulait dire comme
des caravanes qu'est-ce que vous pensez
des femmes mon dieu le plus grand bien
cher
bref
[Musique]
papa
de l'Olympia n'arriverait pas simplement
avec un micro comme ça pour chanter
c'est un spectacle total d'abord je ne
suis jamais arrivé seulement avec un
micro pour chanter des chansons pour
belle qu'elle soit mais cette fois-ci
alors comme on dit populaire j'ai mis le
paquet ce spectacle est un one man show
qui n'en est pas un puisque nous avons 8
artistes nous avons de plus en plus que
ça nous avons 11 artistes en scène
en m'excluant n'est-ce pas nous avons 8
danseuses et trois choristes
[Musique]
aussi toute la famille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le jour de mes 16 printemps
tandis qu'au loin
battait la faire
nous volions sur nos bicyclettes
et nous rions appels dans le jour de mes
16 printemps
je n'étais guère entrepreneur
mais pas de la Lure distraire
quand je fumais les cigarettes des
veinards
qui avaient 20 ans les Renaud je faisais
semblant de cacher des pensées secrètes
quand je te kiné Marinais le jour
demeure 16 printemps
[Musique]